let's say i'm over here i'm going to do
two scenarios so i'm an observer over
here this is me
this is me and then maybe even better i
should just draw my eyeball because
we're going to be observing light so i'm
just going to draw
my eyeball so this is me in the first
scenario and then this is or this is one
of my eyeballs and then this is one of
my eyeballs in the second scenario
now in the first scenario so let me draw
so in both scenarios we're going to have
an object we're going to have some type
of source
of light
but in the first scenario i'm relative
to me the source of light will not be
moving while in the second scenario the
source of light
the source of light just for the sake of
discussion just for fun we'll be moving
at half the speed of light unimaginably
fast speed but let's just assuming it is
so it's moving at it has a velocity of
one half the speed of light one half
light speed
light speed away from me
light speed away
away from me who is the observer
now let's just imagine what would happen
they're both emitting light so and
they're both going to start emitting
light at the exact same time and what
and when they start emitting light
they're both at the exact same distance
from my eye the only difference is is
that this is stationary relative to me
while this is moving away from me at
half the speed of light so let's say
that after some period of time that the
light wave from this this source reaches
my eye
so and then it looks something like this
i'll try my best
i'll try my best to draw it so let's say
i have i want to draw a couple of
wavelengths here so let's say that's
half a wavelength
that's a full wavelength that's another
half a full wavelength another half
full wavelength and then a half and then
a full wavelength so let me see if i can
draw that so it would look
it would look like
full wavelength
full wavelength
full wavelength this is not easy to do
and then you get another full wavelength
so it would look something like that
with the actual waveform and so that
this is just the front of the waveform
is just getting to my eye and then my
eye and then as the waveforms keep going
past my eye it'll my eye will perceive
some type of a wavelength or frequency
and perceive it to be some type of color
assuming that we're in the visible part
of the electromagnetic spectrum now
let's think about what's going to happen
with this source so the first thing is
is that the front of the waveform is
going to reach me at the exact same time
one of those neat and amazing things
about
light traveling in general or especially
in a vacuum
it doesn't matter that this is moving
moving away from me at half the speed of
light the light will still move towards
me at the speed of light it's absolute
doesn't matter if this is going away at
0.9 the speed of light the light will
still will still travel to me at the
speed of light it's very unintuitive
because in our everyday sense if i'm if
i'm moving away from you at half the
speed of a bullet and i shoot a bullet
the bullet will only move towards you
at it'll kind of that that half of its
velocity will be subtracted and it'll
only move towards me at half of its
normal velocity relative to whether it
was stationary but not the case with
light so with that out of the way let's
think about what the waveform would look
like so by the time by the time the
light reached here we need to think let
me actually redraw this over here let me
redraw
this eyeball
let me redraw this eyeball right over
here
so this is me again so by the time the
light reaches my eye so they both
started emitting the light at the exact
same time this guy has traveled half
this distance right if it took light if
it took light a certain amount of time
to get this far this guy will get half
as far in that same amount of time so by
the time the light reaches my eye
this guy will have traveled about half
that distance so he would have traveled
about that far
but just they started emitting the light
at the same time so that very first that
very first photon if you view light as a
particle will reach my eye at the very
same time as the very first photon from
this guy so the waveform is going to
essentially be stretched so instead of
having so we're still going to have
we're still going to have see we're
going to have 1
2
3 4 full wavelengths but they'll now be
stretched let me see if i can draw four
full wavelengths so let me cut this in
half over here let me cut each of those
in half
so each of these are going to be a full
wavelength and then they're going to
have a half wavelength
half wavelength
in
between and so the waveform is going to
look like this
is going to look like this let me try my
best to
draw it this is the hardest part
drawing this stretched out waveform
and there you go it's going to look like
this and so when it gets to my eye my
eye is going to perceive it as having a
longer wavelength even though from the
perspective of each of these objects if
you're traveling with each of them the
the frequency and the wavelength of the
light emitted is the same the only
difference is this guy's moving away
from me or i'm moving away from it
depending on how you want to view it
while i am stationary or it is state
while in this first case the observer
and the source are both stationary now
in this situation what's my eye going to
say well my eye will will get each of
these successive pulses or each of these
successive wave trains and it's going to
say hey there's a longer wavelength here
there is a longer wavelength
longer wavelength
a perceived longer wavelength let me
write that perceived
a perceived longer wavelength here and
also a perceived a perceived lower
frequency
a perceived
lower frequency
so what would that do to the perception
of the light let's say that this is
let's say that this is green light so if
we're a stationary with the observer it
would be green light so let's look at
the electromagnetic spectrum i got this
off of wikipedia
so if i was stationary towards with the
observer we'd be in the
green light part of the spectrum so at
five a 500 nanometer
wavelength
but if all of a sudden because the
object is moving away from me at this
huge velocity
it's the perceived wavelength becomes
wider so from my perception it's going
to have a wider wavelength and you can
see what's happening it will look redder
it will move towards the red part of the
spectrum and this phenomenon
is called redshift
this is called redshift
this is
red
red shift and i've done a bunch of
videos in the physics playlist on the
doppler effect and over there i talk
about sound waves and the perceived
frequency of sound is something travels
towards you versus away from you that's
the exact same idea this is the doppler
effect applied to light and the reason
why dot the doppler effect of works for
light traveling through space and for
sound traveling through air is because a
sound wave in air regardless of whether
it's moving away whether the source is
moving away or towards you the sound
wave is going to move at the speed of
sound
in air at a certain pressure and all of
that and light is the same thing but in
a vacuum it will always it will always
move regardless of the source regardless
of whether what the source is doing the
actual light wave itself will always
travel at the same velocity the only
difference is is that its perceived
frequency and wavelength will change and
now the whole reason why i'm talking
about this is you can use this property
of of light that it gets redshift to see
whether things are traveling away or
towards you
and you know people talk about redshift
because frankly most things are
traveling away from us and that's one of
our the reasons why we why we tend to
believe in the big bang the opposite if
something is traveling towards me at
relative
at super high velocities then we would
have something called and you don't hear
the word it would be violet shift the
frequency would increase
the frequency would increase so it would
look bluer or more purple now the other
thing i want to i want to highlight is
this redshift phenomena this this idea
it doesn't apply only to visible light
so it could even apply to things that we
can't even see so it would only it would
become redder but it's not like you can
even see it could even be applied to
things that are even more red than red
so maybe it's a microwave that is being
emitted but because the source is moving
away from us so fast it could be
perceived as an actual as an actual
radio wave and actually i should have
talked about this in the video on the
microwave background radiation
is that we are perceiving it as
microwaves
but the sources were moving away from us
they were being redshift so they were
not actually emitting microwave
radiation
just what we would we observe and this
was is actually what would be predicted
based on the big bang is the act is
actually microwave radiation so anyway
hopefully that gives you a sense of what
redshift is and now we can use this tool
to uh
to explain why we think many many things
are moving away from us and now let me
just actually
make sure you get that idea if i have
two objects let's say that these are
suns let's say that these these are both
suns or both galaxies either way and
because of other properties and i won't
talk about them right now we know that
they are probably
they are probably emitting light of the
same color they're probably emitting
light of the same color because we know
other properties of that of that star or
of that galaxy now if what we actually
perceive is that this one looks redder
to us than this one then we know that it
is tr we know it is traveling away from
us and the redder it looks the more its
wavelength is spread out relative to
this other star the faster we know that
this is moving away from us